er ließ guttenberg
hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
weihnachtsbäckerei heute wird es wieder
richtig lecker und vor allem richtig
schön ich mache nämlich heute leckere
schokoladen muffins so ein bisschen mit
lebkuchengewürz damit eben schön
weihnachtlich im winterlich schmeckt und
da da oben drauf ist und so eine leckere
creme mit einem leckeren tannenbaum und
das sieht richtig hübsch aus und ich
zeige ich jetzt einfach mal die zutaten
ich werde insgesamt zwölf muffins machen
und habe dafür einfach einen ganz
einfachen rührteig wir brauchen 150
gramm butter de ist schon weiß
150 g zucker 2 eier 160 gramm mehl 30
gramm kakaopulver das ist back cacau
hier habe ich noch etwas milch brauche
ich eventuell hier habe ich einen halben
teelöffel backpulver einfädelt teelöffel
natron falls sie katrin hat nimmt
einfach nochmal die menge an backpulver
hier einen teelöffel zimt eine prise
irgendwas gemahlen und priesen gemahlen
und ich werde meine muffins heute in
diesen süßen papier backförmchen backen
weil die dann aussehen wie so ein
kleiner von blumenkorb und das soll dann
der tannenbaum drin sein und das finde
ich ganz hübsch aber falls ihr sollt ihr
nicht habt könnt ihr einfach normale
papier backförmchen nehmen
zuerst die butter mit dem zucker richtig
schön cremig gerührt und deswegen ist
auch wichtig dass die butterweich ist
dann kommt jetzt der zucker betreiben
und es ist schon ein bisschen weiß
cremig jetzt gebe ich daraus die eier
mit dazu und lasse auch nochmal so etwa
eine minute verrühren
jetzt gebe ich hier noch die trockenen
zutaten alle zusammen rein und dann wird
der teig nur noch ganz kurz verrührt bis
sich alles schön vermengt hat
und wenn das fest ist gebe ich dann noch
ein bisschen milch dazu aber wir schauen
erst mal nach ob es nicht schon reicht
eben ein bisschen was dazu
das war jetzt ungefähr 1 esslöffel milch
und da kommt einfach darauf an wen die
ard verwendet groß sind dann brauchst du
da keine milch und wenn es etwas kleiner
sind müsste ein bisschen milch dazugeben
bis so ein richtig schöner geschmeidiger
teig steht
jetzt nämlich zum teig portioniert
aktionäre mit dem geht es ganz gut
und selbst da einfach ein bisschen teig
in die form rein
die branche lies brauchst du das ganze
jahr bei uns ist es auch kein eis
prozent teig portioniert und so werden
die muffins jetzt bei etwa 180 grad ober
und unterhitze für ungefähr 20 minuten
gebacken es kann auch sein dass etwas
kürzer brauchen würde etwas länger
brauchen
ihr müsst einfach die stäbchen probe mit
dem zahnstocher machen und dann lassen
sie nach dem backen komplett ausfüllen
wenn er muffins gebacken und kühlen
gerade noch ab und in der zeit kann ich
schon mal die deko vorbereiten und ich
werde zu einfach diese tannenbäume
vorbereiten
dafür haben wir hier ein paar was sind
es die gibt inso päckchen am besten in
großen supermärkten bei bedarf also als
zubehör gibt es eine kleine eis waffeln
und eierlikör besser und da ist es
meistens mit dabei und da brauchen wir
jetzt auch zwölf stück dann brauchen wir
ein paar cornflakes und diese werden
dann bei den tannenbäumen ebenso diese
tannenzapfen und um die tannen ein
bisschen darstellen und zum ankleben
verwenden wir hier etwas zuckerglasur
die sp und die werde ich dann einfärben
mit grün wenn man die zwei sachen von de
bug nicht bekommt oder nicht möchte dann
kann man zum beispiel auch zarter
schokolade nehmen dann sind es eben
schwarze tannenbäume sieht auch sehr
edel aus
oder man kann auch weiße schokolade
nehmen muss die aber damit fettlöslichen
farben färben sonst geht es nämlich
nicht
wir werden es jetzt mit den mit der
zucker klasse machen
aber vorher müssen wir hier die
eiswaffel das zurechtschneiden sodass
sie hier komplett gerade ist und das
habe ich jetzt bei denen hier schon
vorbereitet und zeigt euch das jetzt mal
und zwar sitzt man das hier so ein
bisschen an das mal ganz vorsichtig sein
weil ihr sechs sprich ist und brechen
kann
und den rest kann man die sanierer
verlassen oder den rest könnt ihr
zerkrümeln über euer eis oder kickboxen
oder ein hermann brösel boden machen
also bitte nicht wegschmeißen
den rest kann man dann einfach hier so
ein bisschen
genau das macht man nämlich nicht
stelle ich das mal hin wenn es gerade
steht
so ist gut
das stelle ich jetzt kurz zur seite
die habe ich ja schon vorbereitet und
ich mach mir kurz im wasserbad lasst ihr
mein wasser noch mal ganz kurz auf und
es gibt schon mal diese zugang ja so
hier in meinem kleinen teller und da
muss man gleich darauf achten dass kein
wasser in die klausur mit rein kommen
sonst geht die nämlich kaputt das ist
aber auch bei schokolade genau so und
das ist so eine glasur aus zucker und
fett hexe und ich gebe mir jetzt hier
das frisch abgekochtem wasser hier rein
stellen ein schälchen dazu sitzt lässig
das hier einfach ein bisschen auf bis es
komplett geschmolzen ist wer aber zum
beispiel zu hause eine mikrowelle hat
kann einfach dieses schälchen mit dem
schocker drops in die mikrowelle stellen
für etwa 30 sekunden dann umrühren und
ist einfach so lange bis sie komplett
geschmolzen ist das geht viel schneller
auch wären zwei backöfen wir brauchen
noch eine mikrowelle
er koche immer frisch und bei uns gibt
es eigentlich nie was zum erwärmen
und wenn die zuckerglasur geschmolzen
ist könnt ihr jetzt noch ein bisschen
von palm ihn dazu geben dann wird sie
nämlich etwas flüssiger wir brauchen zur
heute etwas flüssiger
das nehmen wir auch klein zu nehmen wir
die lebensmittelfarbe im spiel kommen
das darfst du machen ich helfe dir ein
bisschen geben weiß man nur ein bisschen
und schauen einfach wie dunkel es wird
okay die farbe nämlich ziemlich stark
und sind sehr ergiebig deswegen erstmal
mit wenig starten und dann noch ein
bisschen dazu geht
dann können wir jetzt mit einem pinsel
diese eiswaffel einfach mit pinsel und
da werden wir dann gleich die cornflakes
draufkleben da ruhig ein bisschen
großzügig sein
ich bin schon fertig seid früchte so
großzügig und jetzt werden wir die
konflikts von unten nach oben aufkleben
das mache ich jetzt mal hier werdet ihr
auch kinder richtig schön andrücken
ich habe jetzt diese kahlen bäume ein
bisschen im kühlschrank trocknen lassen
es geht auch wirklich sehr schnell
ich habe einfach einen eingestrichen im
kühlschrank gegeben und immer so weiter
von ihrer klubs partie übrigens neben
mir die ganze zeit und jetzt bestreite
ich die bäume noch mal mit dieser zug
akkus an ihr abi schmeckt dazu kakao
schokolade
richtig schokoladig und stehen gibt es
übrigens überall als in großen
supermärkten und starker mann auf die
farbe bekommen und mit dem lässt sich
wirklich sehr gut arbeiten weil es sich
schnell auflöst im warmen wasserbad und
weil er auch wieder schnell fest wird da
kann man eben ganz schnell arbeiten
jetzt bestreichen wir hier das einfach
richtig schön
und übrigens dieses zb krankheit
ich hoffe sich aufgeräumt andere frauen
haben zwar schuldig serien 200w streusel
dekorieren mit einfach wunderschön
wir haben jetzt mal 5000 bäume fertig
gemacht und ich werde es noch das
frosting machen was wir auf die muffins
drauf geben und dafür brauchen wir nur
drei zutaten und zwar habe ich hier 160
gramm - nougat creme kann nutella sein
kann man kann aber auch eine andere sein
160 km frischkäse und 80 gramm butter
und je nachdem wie viele davon haben
wollt könnt ihr einfach die menge
variieren nutella und frischkäse habe
ich ihm der gleichen menge & butter ist
einfach nur die hälfte davon
es gehe ich jetzt einfach alles zusammen
in eine große schüssel rein und jetzt
wird es einfach miteinander vermixt
das
das reicht auch schon und ich habe zehn
spritzbeutel vorbereitet und für den
hier fühlte stopping hier einfach rein
und hier unten habe ich eine sternstunde
jetzt nehme ich mir einen muffin nämlich
einfach mal den pink und sprit sitzt
hier ein bisschen von der füllung rhein
nicht zu viel damit nicht zu mächtig
wird
und jetzt kann ich hier zum beispiel
diesen weihnachtsbaum nehmen und darauf
setzen
man kann hier einfach so ein paar 25
stück als deko machen und so als
eyecatcher und die anderen kann man ganz
normal dekorieren wenn man möchte oder
man hat viel zeit und viele kinder dabei
die einem helfen
und dann sind wir schon mit unseren
süßen tannenbäumchen fertig und wir
haben jetzt insgesamt für die fünf und
die anderen restlichen etwa über eine
stunde gebraucht weil er auch der papa
mitgeholfen hat und das rezept gibt es
dann zum nachlesen auf sallys - blog.de
ich hoffe dass euch diese idee gefällt
ihr könnt ja uns mal schreiben mit was
man sie noch füllen könnte also was wenn
topping man noch nehmen könnte oder was
ihr vielleicht auch bei einer anderen
deko idee habt und die sanierer und ich
würde kriegen jetzt hier noch ein
bisschen und werden sie uns dann einfach
schmecken lassen
ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen und wir sehen uns dann beim
nächsten mal wieder biss dann tschüss
übrigens findet ihr alle produkte die
ich heute benutzt habe auch bei mir im
shop auf cds - shop.de und ich wünsche
euch jetzt einfach eine richtig schöne
besinnliche weihnachtszeit genießt die
zeit mit euren freunden mit eurer
familie mit